she'd like to better have a good excuse
this time that is the last time he
stands me up how come I have a Jim Tibet
oh who are you who are you look whatever
it is you're selling I'm just not so
good - well what budget lady huh what
did it kill her I guess so who closed
the door come here you can't beat a Game
Boy right now we gotta collect all the
chocolate that [ __ ] boss battle is
the most epic [ __ ] literally the most
epic [ __ ] I have ever play huh oh [ __ ]
is he down there is that like let's go
down here check it out I was also those
sightings I thought that was gonna be
the most epic part of the game but you
bros told me that there's a lot more
epic stuff oh [ __ ] this looks dangerous
oh that was dangerous
hahaha oh it's inverted when I swim in
the water that's why I kept [ __ ] [ __ ]
no whoa whoa whoa whoa that was close go
caca this is gonna take a while
oh I'm at it huh oh I should hold my
breath there that would be awesome
we are going up this looks very very
very very dangerous
uh-huh come on conquer you're better
than that
there we go that was easy that was easy
uh what can beat the great mighty poo I
don't think there could be anything more
Oh shet lava mighty poo maybe I don't
know supposedly the campaign of this
game is actually really long danger poo
well we [ __ ] know that on all right
let's go here oh no it's those guys what
does anyone what's up Oh
all right um can I get Pat mm-hmm you
laughed thank you
[ __ ] that that's all yeah at Oh how much
notice I don't have oh yeah how's
thousand shipped away 500 H come on
shuffle look like it looks like what you
go ahead yeah
hey I'm no copper Oh thousand dollars
hmm I'm either gotta go back that way oh
no poor con game yeah Todd I don't know
it's him ha ha ha Oh God [ __ ] idiots
yeah I'm sure come back let's keep
guarding who did this [ __ ] voice I
catch cake I like the one who's like
where how much money do we have anyway
300 all right I like the one is like
short it was I'd like get away with it
was like what accent is that
well although they all right well it
looks like we're gonna have to go in the
pool all right Prez I think I know what
we're gonna do cuz I came here and it
says no pool balls so let's put some
pool balls there
always doing the opposite of what they
tell you in video games that's like the
first or second room
no dad where's my football hey you are
my prey my pretty little cool Bob why
who came up with ideas like hey you know
what we should do we should have him
rolled pool balls yeah and whose [ __ ]
look like this anyway and you have balls
as poo so many questions what would what
is the squirrel why does everyone think
it's red but it's actually orange why am
i so orange I don't even know anymore
all right pull ball you go down in this
pole it's like a pariah - [ __ ] there I
was I went down yep why would he just
stop off a [ __ ] say yes well that's some
hard [ __ ]
oh you became a butter girl
dad you're Jay nice all right well we
got rid of him so now we can go inside
that [ __ ] thing all right what do I
do with this why was he guarding this
whoa-oh
hey yo yo why do I keep saying that
sorry cut for Bieber yes that's right
[ __ ] down you go [ __ ]
down you [ __ ] gun Dada Dada
Dada Dada Dada oh right the water is
still here what the [ __ ] I thought it
would be empty nowadays huh conquer
conquer all it there there we go now we
got a new place to go at least I thought
I was a goner there for a second uh-huh
new area catfishes I get it
lovely scrolling you thinking Oh know
what you look like you could throw a
little extra my boy
no and we thought you might actually oh
actually I actually cache yes yes yes
they're offering me cash oh hey what's
the catch yeah exactly
this is oh hello Bruce swimming around
just terrible movies we need somebody
disposable but go in and well disposable
thank you thank you so much ah me uni
well you can't expect one of us to go
Canada ladies what good would it do to
do well ass is T is it [ __ ] up myself
yeah yeah don't worry dear
he says geminus side one is a smoker yes
G that foolish
let me hunter listen here you listen to
me I'm listening geez you 10% and that's
a fun look
now hundred percent yes but one thing
we'll remember he's easily a wound up
yes
oh and by the way the sec has a
combination yes let me yes
no well but it's not dangerous down
there for us
come back and we'll open it for you well
good luck on top of you and on effect
within about this moldable yeah now you
realize can't get you slow [ __ ]
oh well cash the meaning of life
I made them okay wait it's a cash up
there I can't cheat um right camera
angle upwards it's really [ __ ]
annoying all right so how do we get rid
of this dog whatever the snoop dog or
whatever he's done it where do you see
anyway
is he over here there's a waterfall
oh there okay hello this is faster than
action Oh
Oh Oh No
all right well they can't go i stock huh
is he is he stuck
I'm scared huh no not shark huh uh-oh
you stock is stock yeah stupid [ __ ] on
that edge okay
how do I kill him let's swim down here
good job conquer conquer Cook County
Kuok I call you that what's going on
here
what that [ __ ] is that okay
oh we're in the safe aren't we yeah we
are behind the safe who would have
thought the safe was a Mexican parents
as razors Jessica she's mentioned her to
me you say shut up what's up well I
guess we got to talk to these fellas
how's it good oh yeah bring me back me
missing cups hey don't ask
aren't you the handsome or yeah and tell
me would you be prepared to do me a
small favor hurtle help of course
okay of course and uh yes I what maybe
yeah
see my other self is lost a fuel is
shall we say friends no I'll get back my
life will be a misery ah hell it is now
just get them back there's a good fellow
don't ever do that again why is some
name run alright there's an elevator up
there let's take it what about you
Mexican man okay fine I'll [ __ ]
everyone's me to [ __ ] up my elevator
just madness Hey timing [ __ ] conquer is
so [ __ ] awesome
it's like the best character ever whoa
whoa uh hey who's that [ __ ] furry Oh
[ __ ] sake okay
whoa whoa uh Concord is drunk the [ __ ]
is he doing what the [ __ ] oh where the
hell did he get a flamethrower frog
seriously this guy's so [ __ ] random
oh whoa oh oh oh why did I see you we're
having Tonka yes
down you go what the hell did I just do
I never understand any of dick oh
there's a spider way up there thank
heavens okay with where did it open
exactly for us apparently it's right
here and I'm such a far away I'm such an
idiot
but hey all right there we go
what were the [ __ ] is laughing what
what's going on in here man come carry
okay guineas chocolate what I need
chocolate too
what
that was an interesting place
what that's a car gets a car gets a car
that's all is it all of them I am edge
oh right in the banana phase what's up
what's up oh there's another one there
all right
well I know what I have to do now is
this how the [ __ ] am I gonna get past
these Swank again what all right that
was one oh you're separating you just
want that thing in your mouth
hey Dale come on put it on put it on -
stick ha ha ha that is a Fanta what is
the booger you up what are you doing not
ha ha ha the wrong way her out yeah [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off
oh this games so [ __ ] weird let's get
another the other two are ago it sounds
like she said period help help
shut up shut up [ __ ] you're gonna
[ __ ] like it alright
put that [ __ ] on yeah cool get to the
one on ah yeah Wow no that's a bit
disturbing honestly alright two more
I mean one more I Mexicans I mean that
card whales right good
whoa we're not lazy set thanks
all right let's make this [ __ ] spin
that the wrong way
have a go yeah we gonna spend Mexicans
is this gonna open the safe or something
then I miss something
they're all [ __ ] spinning on oh there
we go
what oh okay so now it's safe for the
catfishes or whatever just jump off
conquer just jump down and nice jump
tail hmm watching shite that's just it
right but I don't curl it is well free
at last take Jack our bujjamma stable
budget he sexually abuse them not okay
oh no not mr. ha ha ha ha ha ah got it
I don't know what his problem is our
problem our eye that's literally shaken
off of course
now good day to you yeah this [ __ ]
game is [ __ ] school hell are we
yeah come on ladies Caribbean Carol beer
Oh turn it in okay and then where else I
couldn't see
Twilight are they on the Twilight that's
another knife play oh man okay well it
looks like that doggy Doo is out of the
way nowadays oh my go
I can't [ __ ] I mean fishes I did your
thing how do they know okay how are you
splendid thank you tsch friend and get
your vittles today yeah
time it up for that hahaha I need the
combination Thanks no no no no no you
don't you don't seem to understand why
yes you don't understand us we can't go
about giving away classified information
like that just to anybody
oh then [ __ ] come with me open the
thing good cue laters hi neatly I don't
trust these cat [ __ ] what is that
mine's Oh
oh they're gonna die
lead the way I'm leading the way for the
cat folks well fine fine
see if I care cat bucks oh how do i how
do I get out of way cat [ __ ] do
something cat fox why do they have to
make it so difficult
what are they now how daddy huh
okay we met it I don't know how but we
made it what is the same wrong there now
there lady
various oh how did she speak another one
told him his bad temper doesn't ding
yeah yeah well well it it's open the
[ __ ] safe Jesus yeah oh come on it's
just to put it right come ah ha ha ha
gosh damn really wait hear me out
I'm gonna take all the [ __ ] money now
come on all that for that are you cereal
I'm gonna have to end this episode amber
life everything noise this guy coming
today and I'll still knocks episode ome
yay back galactic title screen okay